I want to take up in volume 12, at December the 18th 1920, there are quite
love, love and of thanksgiving for all that God operated in the celestial mother.
Louisa said she was all afflicted without Jesus, while she was praying she
actually felt him near and he said to her, "Ah my daughter, things are going to get
worse." This is 1920, so you have the communist revolution creating the USSR
and creating havoc in all of those incredible nations and the persecutions
of the Christians and the destruction of religion and the worship of the state.
God is thrown out completely and other nations followed suit as you know with
Paul Pot and people like that in the east. "Ah my daughter, things get worse. It will
enter like a whirlwind and shake everything. The it I think is this communist
revolution. It will rain for a time like a whirlwind and as a whirlwind it will
also end. It will come, do its destruction and go. Now we've lived through the time
when officially the USSR collapsed in 1998 and it collapsed without anybody
firing a shot. The Italian government lacks the ground under its feet so
Italy was going to have a terrible effect from all of this because they
absorbed communism and since Italy was the heart of the church it was a
devastating kick in the teeth to Jesus. The Italian government lacks the ground
under its feet and it does not know where to reach to," he said, "justice of God."
After this, Louisa said she felt outside of herself and she found herself
together with Jesus and so classed to him and he with her that she could almost
not see his divine person. So a lovely image of union there and I don't know
how she said, "My sweet Jesus, while I'm classed to you, I want to attest to you, my
love, my gratitude and everything that the creature has the duty to do because
you have created our immaculate Queen Mother." So here she is thanking the Lord
on behalf of all of us for creating our blessed Mother. She's the most beautiful
the holiest and a portant of grace enriching her with all gifts and making
her also our Mother. And this I do in the name of all past, present and future. I
want to catch in flight each act of the creatures, each word, each thought, each
heartbeat, each step and in each of them I want to tell you that I love you, I thank
you, I bless you, I adore you for all that you have done for my celestial
Mother and yours. Jesus enjoyed her making this act and he said to her, "My
daughter, I was anxiously awaiting for this act of yours in the name of all
generations. My justice, my love, felt the need for this requital because great
are the graces that descend upon everyone for having been so enriched my
Mother. Yet there's never a word, never a thank you to me. This is human beings
accepting whatever is given to them and it doesn't occur to them to say thanks.
Another day I was saying to my beloved Jesus, "Everything is over for me,
suffering visits of Jesus, everything," and he immediately said, "Have you
perhaps stopped loving me or doing my will?" And Louisa said, "No, may this never be."
Well, he said, "If this is not there, nothing's over." Again, she's falling into
the trap of looking at her feelings and not looking at the reality of her
condition of union with God. And so it's a timely warning for us not to be
governed by how we feel but to look at the reality of our union with God. So
December the 22nd 1920, the creative power is found in the divine will.
Louisa said, "I was thinking about the most holy will of God saying to
myself, 'What a magic force this divine will has, what power, what enchantment.'
And while I was thinking of this, Jesus said, 'My daughter, even the mere words
will of God contains creative power.'" Isn't that extraordinary? Therefore, it has
the power to create, to transform, to consume, and to make new torrents of light
and love and sanctity run in the soul. Psalm 36 verses 9 to 10, "The torrents of
your delight glow over me." Only in the fiat is this creative power. And if the
priest consecrates me in the host, it's only because of the divine will that gave
this power to those words which are pronounced over the holy host. If the
divine will didn't want it, it wouldn't happen. So everything comes from and
everything is found in the fiat. And if at the mere thought of doing my will, the
soul feels sweetened, strengthened, and changed because by thinking of doing my
will, it is as if she were placing herself on the way to find all the goods.
What will not happen if she actually does it? So if even speaking the words
will of God, even thinking about the possibility of living in the will of God
brings so much grace, what's going to happen when we actually surrender? I want
to give you James 1, 22, where James tells us to stop just looking at the word, but
live it. Let it become a reality in our lives. And that is the challenge here at
the end of Volume 12. You've heard everything now go and live it. So after
this Louisa recalled that years before Jesus had said to her, we will present
ourselves before the supreme majesty with written on her farheads in indelible
characters. We want death to give life to our brothers. We want pains to free
them from eternal pains. We've had that earlier in Volume 12. Now I said to myself,
how can I do this if he doesn't come? I could do it together with him, but I'm
not able to do it by myself. There's your John 15 5. I can't do it without him, and
Philippians 4 13, I can do all things in Christ who gives me the strength. And then
she said, how can I suffer so many deaths? And blessed Jesus moving in her
interior, which of course is Luke 17 21, and one Corinthians 3 16. He said, my
daughter, you can do it always and at every instant, because I am always with
you, and I never leave you. Now I never leave you is Joshua 1 5. And then I want
you to know how these deaths are and how they're formed. I suffer death when my
will wants to operate some good in the soul, and the soul departing from me, it
brings with itself the grace. Sorry. Let me go back on that. Jesus said, I
suffer death when my will wants to operate some good in the soul. So that
good departing from me, it brings with itself the grace and the help which are
needed in order to do that good. So we call that prevenient grace. That's what
Church officially calls it. That is the grace to do something. We can't do any
good by ourselves. John 15 5, without me, you can do nothing. And so if the Lord
sees that we want to do something good, He actually gives you the
prevenient grace, the grace that enables you to do it. Now, but if the creature is
reluctant, it is as if my will suffered a death, because this good is not going to
go out from His will. Oh, how many deaths my will suffers. Death in the soul is when
I want her to do some good, and by not doing it, she dies to that good. That
means there's an opportunity for me to forgive an I let it pass, or there's an
opportunity for me to be patient and kind, and I let it go. Her will dies to that
good. So if the soul is not in continuous act of doing my will, she suffers as
many deaths for as many times as she doesn't do it. She dies to that light,
and she dies to that light which she should have had by doing this good. She
dies to that grace, and she dies to those carisms. He's trying to let us know how
serious it is to let an opportunity for grace pass us by. Now, I will tell you what
your deaths are, he said, to Louisa, with which you could give life to your
brothers. When you feel you are without me and your heart is lacerated, that's the
deprivations, and you feel an iron hand that grips it, you feel a death. But
rather more than a death because death would be life for you. In other words, if
she dies to ghost heaven. This death could give life to your brothers. In other
words, all the things that cause you suffering, distress, disturbance, pain,
trials, everything, they should all be offered with the sufferings, redemptive
sufferings of Jesus in his will to give life to souls. Otherwise, we're losing
immense opportunities for divine currency. This death, he said, could give life to
our brothers, because this pain and this death contain a divine life. An immense
life, a creative strength, they contain everything. Now, Louisa is suffering this
in the divine will. That's why Jesus is saying it has a divine life and creative
strength and immense life. It is a death and pain that contains an eternal and
infinite value. Of course, if you offer that for others, you're going to get
tremendous fruit. Therefore, how many lives could you give to your brothers? I
will suffer these deaths together with you, because they are one. They are
inseparable. I will give them the value of my death. So we join our deaths to
his to get his infinite merits. So as to make life come out of that death. So take
a look at how many deaths you suffer. Each time you want me and you do not find
me, it is a real death for you. Because you truly do not see me. So Sam 22 verse 1,
"My God, my God, why have you forsaken me?" And you don't feel me. For you it is
death. It is martyrdom. And what is death for you can be life for others. So he's
letting her see just how precious the deep privation is if she would turn it
into divine currency. So that's 2 Corinthians 1 verses 3 to 7. So we go to
December the 25th, 1920, and Jesus says that his sacramental lot is even harder
than the lot, the circumstances that he experienced in his infancy. So Louisa
has been obviously doing the Christmas novina meditating on the passion of
Jesus in his mother's womb and then you have this message coming through. As I
was in my usual state, I found myself outside of myself together with Jesus.
I was walking a long way and on this journey I walked with Jesus. And then I
was with my Queen mother. If Jesus disappeared, I found myself with mother.
And if she disappeared, I found myself with Jesus. And during this walk, I want
to give you Genesis 3.8 because God walked with Adam and the cool of the day.
During this walk they told me many things. Jesus and mother were very
affable with an enchanting sweetness. I forgot everything. I forgot my bitterness
and even their privations. I thought I'd never lose them again. All how easy it is
to forget evil in the face of good. And sometimes it's easy to forget good in
the face of evil. Now at the end of the walk our celestial mother took me in her
arms. I was very little, very little. In other words, she was an infant because
it's the 25th of December, isn't it? And she said to me, "My daughter, I want to
strengthen you in everything." And it seemed that she was marking my forehead
with her holy hand, as if she were writing and placing a seal on it. And then
it seemed as if she were writing in my eyes, in my mouth, in my heart, in my
hands, in my feet placing a seal on them. I wanted to see what she was writing but
I couldn't read the script. Only on my mouth I saw two letters which said
annihilation of every taste. And immediately I said, "Thank you, mother. You
take away from me every taste which is not Jesus." I wanted to understand more
but mother told me it's not necessary for you to know. Trust me, I did to you what
was necessary. She blessed me and she disappeared. So I want to give you
Revelation 13 verses 16 to 17 where Satan also puts a mark or a seal on the
people who give themselves to him. And before that, I think it's in Revelation
7, or a little bit later, maybe Revelation 8, where before the great
chastisements, the Lord puts a seal on all who love him. So obviously we are all
marked and this mark can be seen in the spiritual realm. We can't see it but the
spiritual realm knows exactly who's who. Afterwards my sweet Jesus came back, he
was a little tender baby, it's the 25th to December of course. Wailing and crying
and shivering with cold, he threw himself into my arms to be warmed, I
squeezed him so very tightly to myself. And according to my usual way, I fused
myself in his will in order to find the thoughts of all, with mine, to surround
shivering Jesus with the adoration from all created intellects, in order to find
the gazes of all and to make all look at Jesus and distract him from the crying,
in order to find the mouths, the words, the voices of all creatures. That all might
kiss him so as not to make him wail and they might warm him with their breath.
And while I was doing this, the infant Jesus stopped wailing and crying and as
though warmed he then speaks to her as an adult. "My daughter," he said, "and I
infused an infant, how can she be my daughter?" So what you're having there is
a different image is given to you. "My daughter, did you see what made me
shiver and cry and wail? It's the abandonment of creatures." Now this is
1921, so you're talking about atheistic materialism and communism and
Marxism and Freemasonry and all that goes with it. "You placed them all around me.
I felt I was being watched and kissed by all so I stopped crying." In other words,
she was making an effort to requite him on the part of human beings for all that
he has done for us. However, he's going to make a comparison now because Jesus is
not coming to her as in the days of his incarnation. Jesus is with us in the
tabernacles in the sacred host. And so he says to her, "Please know that my
sacramental lot is even harder than my lot as an infant." Though cold, the grotto
was spacious and had air to breathe. The host is cold, but it is so small that I
almost lack air. In the grotto, I had a manger with a little hay for a bed. In my
sacramental life, I don't even have hay. I've nothing but hard and ice-cold metals
for a bed. In the grotto, I had my dear mother, who took me very often in her
arms with her most pure hands. She covered me with ardent kisses. In order to warm
me, she soothed my crying. She nourished me with her most sweet milk. In my
sacramental life, it's all the opposite. I don't have a mother. And if they take
me, I feel the touch of unworthy hands which smell like earth and muck. Oh, how I
feel their stench more than manure that I smelled in the grotto. So there I want
to give you Hebrews 12, 14. Without holiness, we cannot enter the presence of
God. And you see the Lord responding to the sin that approaches him. So I want to
give you Habakkuk 1, 13 as well. Lord, your eyes are too holy to look upon evil.
So he says, I feel the touch of unworthy hands which smell like earth and muck. Oh,
how I feel their stench more than the manure I smelled in the grotto. Instead
of covering me with kisses, they touch me with irreverent acte. Instead of milk,
they give me the bile of sacrileges of indifference and of coldness. In the
grotto, St. Joseph never left me without the light of a little lantern at night.
Here in the sacrament, how many times I remain in the dark also at night. So he's
obviously referring to the lack of the tabernacle light there. Oh, how much more
painful is my sacramental lot? How many hidden tears not seen by anyone? How many
whales not listened to? If my lot as an infant moved you to pity, much more
should my sacramental lot move you to pity. So there's a graphic description of
the way Jesus actually feels in our tabernacles. And yet most Catholics treat
the Lord in the Holy Eucharist as if he had no feelings. Yes, we do say in words
that we receive the body, blood, soul and divinity of Jesus Christ. In other words,
we receive the whole of Jesus. And yet we don't think he has any feelings or that
he has any personal response to us, or that he reacts to us in any way, or that
he sees our own words in us. It's not logical, is it? It means that our reactions
actually make the statement that we don't really believe. January the 5th, 1921.
"The true life of the soul done in my will is nothing other than the formation
of the life of Jesus in the soul." So this is a very important message. I mean
they're all important, but some of them stand out. "Continue in my usual state I
was praying and while praying I intended to enter the divine will." So notice they
deliberate entering into the divine will. And so making all that exists in the
divine will, my own. Look at this. This is very important. "Since nothing escapes
the divine will past, present or future, and making myself the crown of all, in the
name of all, I brought my homage, my love, my reparation, etc., before the divine
majesty." Now my beloved Jesus moving in my interior told me, "My daughter, the
true life of the soul done in my will is nothing other than the formation of her
life in mine." I want to give you two Corinthians 5, 17. What matters is that
we become a whole new creation in Christ. We become another Christ. So I give my
own shape to everything that she does. I did nothing but make all the acts that I
did, both interior and exterior, fly within the divine will. I made each thought of
my mind fly and hovering over each thought of the creature, which all
existed in my will. My thought hovering overall made itself as though the crown
of each human intelligence. So now you see the way Louisa has just been praying.
I make myself the crown of all. It made itself as though the crown of each
human intelligence and brought the homage, the adoration, the glory, the love, the
reparation of each creation thought to the divine majesty of the Father. The same
with my gaze, my word, my motion, and my step. Now in order to live in my will, the
soul must give the shape of my mind to her mind. That's Philippians chapter 2
verses 1 to 5. Let this mind be in you, which was also in Christ Jesus. And also I
want to give you Ephesians chapter 4. The soul must give the shape of my mind to
her mind, the shape of my gaze, of my word, of my motion to hers. So everything in us
has got to be transformed into Jesus, our thinking, our wanting, our willing, our
desiring, our acting, everything. And by doing this, the soul loses her shape and
acquires mine. So we lose the likeness of the old man, and we gain the likeness of
the new man, which is Christ. Now the old man and new man are the language of Saint
Paul. And you'll hear this language in Ephesians, in Colossians, in Philippians,
just to give you three of his letters. The soul does nothing other than give
continuous death to the human life and continuous life to the divine will. Now
here we've got something utterly basic that we have been given many times, which
Jesus is a very good teacher. So a teacher knows that the fact that you've
said something once does not mean that the pupils actually get it. And so the
teacher revises things, and will say things over and over again from
slightly different angles in order to get the pupils to hear. And that's
exactly what Jesus does here. And so he says that in order to live in the divine
will, it'll only happen if you put down the human will. It's as simple as that.
And so we said back in Volume 1 and 2 that our motto has to be, "Not my will,
but thine be done, O Lord." In this way the soul will be able to complete the life
of my will within herself, keep putting down the human will, and the divine will
will take over. Otherwise this prodigy, this shape fully modeled on mine, will
never be accomplished completely. Now it's the completely that's terribly
important because generous souls will give a lot to the Lord, but they may
balk at the little word completely. There may be something of themselves that
they want to hold on to. We don't like surrendering completely because that
means that you're not in control. Somebody else has the controls. And so
it's hard for us to hand over the controls to the Lord. Only my will, which
is eternal and immense, allows her to find everything. So if we haven't
surrendered completely, we cannot enter completely into all the wonders of the
divine will. The divine will reduces the past and the future to a single point.
This is this singularity which is God. Infinitely small, infinitely immense. It's
incredible. And in this single point she finds all the beating hearts, all the
living minds, and all of my works in act. So in that singularity or that single
point, there's neither past nor future, everything is present because it's
outside of the dimensions of time and space. And the soul making my will, her
own, is able to do everything. She's able to satisfy for all, to love for all, and
to do good to all and to every single individual as if they were all one. Who
can ever reach such an extent? No virtue, no heroism, not even martyrdom, can stand
before my will. So the greatest of the greats before the divine will have to bow.
And yet the least of us in the divine will is privileged more than our
greatest canonized saints. It's totally incredible. All he said, all remain behind
the operating done in my will, therefore be attentive and let the mission of my
will have its fulfillment in you. Amen. We've all got to say amen to that but we've
all got to pay the price which is laying down the human will before the
divine. So January the 7th 1921, the smile of Jesus when he sees he can see
the first fruits, the children of the divine will. Now Jesus had to wait until
enough of the priests around Louisa came to understand something of the divine
will and began to try and live it themselves. And then that they would
spread it out and so very slowly the message of the divine will would begin
to spread out among others. And so this is 1921 very early for this. As I was in
my usual state, my beloved Jesus came and surrounded my neck with his arm, that
song of songs to six. And when you drew near my heart and holding his breast
between his hands, he pressed it to my heart and rivelets of milk came out of
it. He filled my heart with those rivelets of milk and he told me, my daughter, do
you see how much I love you? I wanted to fill all of your heart with the milk of
grace and love. Now when you go back to volumes one to four, the first time we
met her receiving this milk from the Lord, all I could say to you was that
other saints had experienced the same thing. Here Jesus is actually naming it
that it's milk of grace and love. So everything you say and do will be nothing
other than the outpouring of the grace that I have filled into you. That's John
7 37 to 39. You will do nothing. You will just place your will at the mercy of the
divine will and I will do everything. You see it's so easy. All we've got to do is
surrender and let him do what he wants to do. You will be nothing but the sound of
my voice, the bearer of my will, the destroyer of the virtues in a human way,
the restorer of the virtues in a divine manner which are founded on an eternal
immense infinite point. How do you respond to that except say amazing? We just have
to surrender and let him take over. It's about that simple. After a little while
Jesus came back and Louisa was feeling all annihilated especially in thinking
about certain things which are not necessary to write here. She said her
affliction was at its summit and she said to herself how can this be might
Jesus do not permit this? Maybe you want the will but not the act of this
particular sacrifice and then in the hard station which I find myself I aspire
to nothing but heaven. But Jesus coming out from my interior burst into sobbing
and I could hear that sob resound in heaven and on earth but as he was about
to stop sobbing I a smile arose and just like the sob the smile reverberated in
heaven and on earth because its divine will. It could be heard everywhere.
Louisa said she remained enchanted and Jesus said my beloved daughter after the
great sorrow which creatures have given to me in these sad times that's the sobbing.
To the extent of making me cry and because of this crying of God could you
imagine that we can cause God to cry? It resounds in heaven and on earth. A smile
will take over which will also fill heaven and earth with gladness and this
smile will arise on my lips when I see the first fruits the children of my will.
So the children of my will is Romans 8, 19 and living not in the human sphere but
in the divine sphere. He said heaven will begin to smile when the children of the
divine will are born. I will see them all marked with the eternal immense
infinite divine will. I will see that eternal point which has life only in
heaven flow upon the earth and mold the souls with its infinite principles with
divine acting with the multiplication of acts within one single act. So all of our
acts in the divine will are all inside the fiat of God. Our little acts in his
act our little fiat inside his fiat our drop of wine our drop of water in the
wine of his redemption. It's our participation and just as creation came
out from one fiat in the fiat it will be fulfilled. Only the children of the
divine will will accomplish everything in the fiat and in my fiat which will
have life in them I will receive complete glory, complete love, complete
reparation, complete thanksgiving and complete praise for everything and for
everyone. Complete means nothing will be left out nothing will be missing. My
daughter things return there where they come from. Everything came out from the
fiat and in the fiat everything will return to me. These children of the
divine will will be few but in the fiat they will give me everything. It doesn't
matter to the Lord that it's only a few in number. What matters is that they are
there and that there are a few and that we actually do live the divine will and
that we do live it on behalf of all our brothers and sisters to take them with
us to heaven. So January the 10th 1921 the fiat Mickey of the Most Holy Virgin.
Louisa said I was concerned about was written above and I said to myself I
don't know what Jesus wants from me yet he knows how bad I am and how good at
nothing I am and Jesus said my daughter remember that years ago I asked you if
you wanted to live in my will. You see the Lord will always come back and ask
you do you want to live this way even though you've told him yes and he has
celebrated that yes. It's like a couple who signed their lives over to each other
on the day of their marriage but they have to tell each other that they love
each other on every day that they live together otherwise that marriage can
break down. He said years ago I asked you if you wanted to live in my will and
since I wanted you in my will I want to do to pronounce your yes in my own
volition. This yes was bound to an eternal point that's that singularity of
the divine will and it was bound to a will which will never end. This yes of
yours is in the center of my will surrounded by infinite immensity. So on
the one hand you can say it's a singularity it's a single point and on
the other you have to say it's total infinite immensity. Now our poor minds
are not able to handle those two extremes. This yes is in the center of my
volition surrounded by infinite immensity and if it tries to go out it
can't find a way. You will hear Louisa say this when you get to the higher
volumes. Therefore at your little oppositions at some discontent of yours I
laugh he said and I enjoy myself because I see you like those people who are
bound of their own will in the depths of the sea and wanting to go out they find
nothing but water. And since they are bound in the depths of the sea they feel
the bother of wanting to go out and in order to remain tranquil and happy they
plunge themselves even more into the depths of the sea. In the same way in
seeing you perplexed as though wanting to go out and in seeing that you are
unable to do it being bound by your own yes. You see the bond is there. You plunge
yourself even more into the depths of my will and I laugh and I enjoy myself and
then do you think is something trivial and easy to move from within my divine
will. You would move an eternal point. She's going to discover as we move into
higher volumes that once this commitment is made shifting from it has frightening
consequences. You would move an eternal point and if you knew what it means to
move an eternal point you would tremble with fright. He's not going to talk about
this until later now. And then he added I asked the first yes in my fiat of my
dear mother. Now her yes was given at the very first instant of life and then it
was pronounced in her later years in Luke 1 3 38 when she said "fiat michis a
condom verbum to him." "O the power of her fiat in my will," he said. As soon as the
divine fiat met with the fiat of my mother the two became one. My fiat raised
her, divinised her, overshadowed her and with no human intervention conceived me
the Son of God. Only in my fiat could she conceive me. My fiat communicated to her
immensity, infinity, fecundity in a divine manner and therefore the immense
eternal infinite one could be conceived in this creature. As soon as she said
"fiat michis a condom verbum to him," Luke 1 38, "not only did she take possession
of me but she overshadowed all creatures and all created things." She felt within
herself the life of all creatures and from that moment she began to act as the
mother and the queen of all. Why would this happen? Because she has now conceived
him who has the divine will in him as nature. She has the divine will in her by
grace and so the divine will in her and the divine will in Jesus match and marry
each other. How many portents does this yes of my mother not contain? If I wanted
to tell them all it never stopped listening. So in other words no matter how
much explanation Jesus gives there's no possibility of plumbing the depths of
this. And so because Blessed Mother has conceived the eternal one in her womb
everything that is in the divine will is now in her and that's why she felt
inside of herself the life of all creatures and from that moment realized
she was the mother of all. It's confirmed at the foot of the cross. Now
Jesus said I asked a second yes in my will from you Louisa and you though
trembling pronounced it. This yes in my volition will accomplish its portents.
It will have its divine fulfillment but you should follow me and plunge
yourself more deeply into the immense sea of my will and I'll take care of
everything. My mother did not think about how I would manage to incarnate
myself in her. The only thing she asked was that how could it happen when she
wasn't going to have relations with man? She just said fear me he be it done to
me and I took care of how to be incarnated and the same will happen for
you. Now when Jesus explains this a lot of the difficulties that you might
experience in the divine will just simply disappear. You desire it he said I'll do
it. Our job is to put down the human will and let the divine will take over. Our
job is to surrender. Our job is to let our will click finally permanently
eternally into the divine will now and then he will work his wonders upon the
earth. So, January the 17th 1921 continues on the Fiat Mihi of Blessed
Mother. Louise has said I felt my poor mind immersed in the immense sea of the
divine volition. I could see the mark of the Fiat everywhere I saw it in the sun
and it seemed to me that the echo of the Fiat in the sun brought me divine love
which darted through me wounded me and flashed through me and I on the wings of
the Fiat of the Sun went up to the eternal one bringing in the name of the
whole human family the love which darted wounded and flashed through the supreme
majesty. In other words there's the circle of love complete. Now the Sun is
inanimate matter and Louisa is the speaking creation so the speaking
creation takes the love of the inanimate matter and brings it back to the source
of love and so that is the role that the Lord has given to us as the speaking
creation that in the name of all we can actually speak for them and offer what
they want to offer to God. And I said in your Fiat you gave me all this love and
only in your Fiat can I actually return it to you. And then secondly Louisa said
I looked at the stars and I could see the Fiat in them and in their sweet and me
clivering this Fiat brought me peaceful love, sweet love, hidden love,
compassionate love in the very night of sin. Now she's thinking of the whole
human race of course and I in the Fiat of the stars and in the name of all brought
to the throne of the eternal one this peaceful love in order to put peace
between heaven and earth and the sweet love of the loving souls the hidden love
of many others and the love of creatures when after sin they would come back to
God. But who can say all that I understood and did in the many Fiat's which were
scattered all over creation it would be too long so I'll stop here. Then my sweet
Jesus took my hands in his own and squeezing them tightly he told me my
daughter the Fiat is all full of life even more it is life itself so I want to
give you John 14 6 there I am the way the truth and the life and this is why I
want to give you sorry John chapter one verses one to four as well and this is
why all lives and all things come out from the Fiat. Creation came out from my
Fiat therefore in each created thing one can see the mark of the Fiat so what
he's saying is Louisa has seen this and so he's emphasizing it for her making
sure that she understands what she has seen. Redemption came out of the Fiat
Mickey of my dear mother pronounced in my volition just as Louisa pronounced
her Fiat in the divine volition as well and carrying the same power of my
created Fiat that's the amazing thing that a creature can operate with the
same power it's amazing therefore there's nothing in redemption which does not
contain the mark of the Fiat Mickey of my mother. Let me say that again there is
nothing in redemption that doesn't have the mark of Blessed Mother's Fiat. Even
my very humanity he said my steps my words my works they were all marked with
the Fiat Mickey my pains my wounds my thorns my cross my blood had the mark of
her Fiat Mickey because things carry the mark of the origin from which they came
that's a very important thing we come from God so we have the mark of creatures
that have come from God. Jesus said my origin in time was the Fiat Mickey of the
Immaculate Mother and therefore all of my works carry the mark of that Fiat Mickey.
So her Fiat Mickey is in each sacramental host if a man rises again from sin if
the newborn is baptized if heaven opens to receive souls it is the Fiat Mickey
of my mother that marks everything follows everything and from it everything
proceeds. Oh wow the power of that Fiat. It rises at every instant it multiplies
and it becomes the life of all goods. Now he said I want to tell you why I asked
for your Fiat for your yes in my volition. So Louisa had to give her yes in the
divine Fiat just as Blessed Mother gave her yes in the divine Fiat. I want the
prayer which I taught the Fiat Vellontas to a secret in Chelo at Intera. I want
this prayer of so many centuries and so many generations to have its fulfillment
and its completion. This is why I wanted another yes in my volition, another Fiat
containing the creative power. I want the Fiat that rises at every instant and
multiplies in everyone. I want in one soul my own Fiat which ascends to my
throne and by its creative power brings on earth the life of the Fiat on earth as
it is in heaven. The only divine Fiat can do it so Louisa's Fiat had to be in the
divine Fiat. Surprised and annihilated hearing this Louisa said Jesus what are
you saying? Yet you know how bad and incapable I am and Jesus' answer is
wonderful straight from scripture. He said my daughter it is my usual way to
choose the most abject, unable, poor souls for my greatest works. Thanks be to God
that means the chance for you and me. Well if you go to one Corinthians 1 verses
26 to 31 St. Paul will tell you this in plain English even though it was written
in Greek. He said he chooses the weak things of this world to confound the
strong and Jesus says in two Corinthians 12 and nine my power works best in
weakness. So if you like the rest of us think that you're unable incapable,
unworthy, too small, too unholy, too everything then you're the right candidate
just surrender to him. I think it's brilliant, absolutely brilliant and that's
why St. Paul says in one Corinthians chapter one where are the philosophers?
Where are all the big heads trying to work everything out and they haven't
a clue about the way God actually works and God is working under their noses and
they can't see it. My daughter it's my usual way to choose the most abject, the
most unable, poor souls for my greatest works. Well I don't know about you but I
praise him from the depths of my being for that. Even my mother had nothing
extraordinary in her external life, no miracles, not a sign that would
distinguish her from anybody else. Her only distinction was perfect virtue but
nobody paid any attention. They would only think she was nice. And if to other
saints I gave the distinction of miracles I want to give you John 1412 for
that. My disciples will do the same works as I do when I go to the Father. So if to
other saints I gave the distinction of miracles and I adorned others with my
wounds as the victim's souls to my mother nothing, nothing. And yet she was
the portant of portance, the miracle of miracles, the true and perfect crucified
one. No one was like her. And so with this wonderful praise of Jesus I want to
remind you of a beautiful hymn we used to sing when Latin was still our language,
the language of beauty and and the liturgy. We used to sing to her to Gloria
Jerusalem, to Laetitia Israel, to Honore the Vicencia Populi Nostri. You are the
glory of Jerusalem, the joy of Israel, the honor of our people. And it's taken
from the book of Judith chapter 15 verses 9 to 10. To Gloria Jerusalem, to
Laetitia Israel, to Honore the Vicencia Populi Nostri. To Radvokata,
Vicatorum, to Radvokata, Vicatorum,
O Maria. So we add the words, you are all beautiful, "Totapulcra" is Maria.
And you are the one who intercedes for us sinners. She was the portant of
portance, the miracle of miracles, the true and perfect crucified soul. And then
Jesus said, "I usually act like a master who has two servants. I love this story.
Absolutely love it." He said, "One of them seems a herculean giant good at
everything. The other one is short, unable, and seems to be good at nothing. Not
any important service. Now if the master keeps them, it's more for charity and
out of fun. Now having to send a million, whatever the currency is, a billion to
another town, what does he do? He calls the little and the incapable one and
entrusts this great sum of money to him. Saying to himself, "If I give it to the
giant, all will fix their attention on him. Thieves will attack him and rob him.
And if he tries to defend himself with his herculean strength, he may be wounded. I
know he's capable, but I want to spare him. I do not want to expose him to obvious
danger. On the other hand, no one will pay attention to the little one, knowing him
to be incapable. In other words, nobody would believe that God is giving you and
me such an unbelievable gift as to live in the divine well. They will literally
push it aside, laughing. No one would think that I would entrust such an
important sum to this person. So he will come back safe and sound. The poor
incapable one is surprised that the master would trust him. When he could
have used the giant and all trembling and humble, he goes to deposit the great
sum with no one gaining to give him even a glance, and he returns safe and sound to
his master, more trembling and humble than before. Look at the divine wisdom.
Isn't it absolutely incredible? That's what I do, Jesus said. The greater the work
that I want to do, the more I choose, abject poor ignorant souls, with no
outward appearance which may expose them. The abject state of the soul will serve as
safe custody for my work. The themes of self-esteem and love of self will not
pay attention to her, knowing her inability, and she humble and trembling
will carry out the office entrusted by me, knowing that she has done nothing by
herself and that I do everything in her. I think that's beyond brilliant and I'm
going to stop there.